[Music]
in Good Samaritan news hmm submitted by
good lovin hey Chicago man was ordered
by the city to stop offering the
homeless shelter from the cold why
they're like let them burn in the
[ __ ] ice what
frostbite frostbite okay you know ice
burning yeah yeah so this man his name's
Greg from Illinois he has been opening
his home for the homeless the city told
him that he has to stop because it's
against city code so that's why they
told him it's against the rules but not
against humanity' [ __ ] yeah
pretty much yes this is when human like
regular ethics goes against man's law he
initially had set up a shelter and back
in 2016 in his garage but then
paramedics had to go attend like some
man that was having like a heart
condition
not a crack overdose Adam a that heart
condition once the paramedics got there
they alerted the city officials that he
had like a shelter in his garage and so
that's on this city the city said like
tattle tellin ass [ __ ] yeah and
then so he he ended up examining the
city code and he found a loophole that
allowed him to have like slumber parties
he moved the entire shelter to his
basement and then he ended up
introducing activities necessary for it
to be considered a slumber party so he
can get so they had twister mhm
he's like raining the homeless people's
hair they're a Brady holy sweet boy I
heard they had a pillow fight seven
minutes in heaven seven minutes in
heaven spin the bottle
oh that's like a party without parents
yeah cuz I was picturing two homeless
guys making out yeah
yeah that's not right go ahead there huh
well he said spin the bottle up I was
following you I was just handing you Jia
I know that's nothing no no I a great
example to follow so I think I was like
oh I watched too much lesbian slumber
party pornos anyways yeah go I backed
okay they're playing twister all right
homeless guys are playing twister and
the cops come in hi no shelter Hey and
then they catch them in like red hand
yellow twister
okay I'm clever party slumber party all
right I thought it was a oh yeah it's
like well these aren't homeless they're
my friends so no the city ended up
saying like he doesn't qualify for that
loophole because that loophole is mainly
only for children's parties also their
age it really that and also the fact
that his basement is not like up to code
for sleeping regulations so like the
ceiling is too low there's other things
so for that reason they told him like
you need to shut down or else we're
gonna condemn your house tango this is
an Illinois Elkin everybody looks like
this is Greg here Greg in his basement
so you seem like you told us himself I
thought he was a homeless guy yeah I
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
like great beard like back here is like
all the cots in the sleeping bag that he
has for almost people he's named like
you know he's been trying to help
homeless people for a while now and like
he considers them his friends and so
like now it sucks that they have to be
forced outside because there's a lot of
shelters that they won't even open their
doors and until temperatures drop to a
certain degree and I think it's like 215
degrees
Oh 15 people are dying in that weather
so I thought homeless people were like
birds will they travel to the warm areas
all like they might be homeless
migration like well we gotta go back
down to Florida yeah kind of cold in
Chicago it was even snowing in Florida
just recently like if I was homeless in
Chicago I'd [ __ ] leave that place I'm
going some warm yeah well dude I
remember hearing something like
to give plane tickets to homeless Kauai
Hawaii yeah they got they got in trouble
other cities got sued by Honolulu
because people they found out that all
these homeless people were just given
one-way tickets like they would clean
them up one-way tickets they drop them
off and then they're like how we're all
these homeless people coming from could
it's an island you know like it's like
we're the [ __ ] and that's what
happened yeah it's crazy that this guy
is trying to make a difference and do
something positive and the city comes
along and goes now instead of finding a
solution like okay this guy obviously
has a passion to do something like this
we do have these other missions or
whatever maybe you can work in
collaboration because it seems like it's
a win-win and it seems like he's doing
the job for the city and overall the
state so you would think that the city
would be like all right yes you know we
might have to shut you down because we
want to keep everyone safe but because
you're doing a good thing we're gonna
hook you up with this or like you said
offer a solution that gets really [ __ ]
up yeah well like before he had tried
like he did open up a shelter at a
church but then apparently I like a
falling out with the partner like he
opened it up with and then that that was
left there and then now like he tried
doing it in his own home he just can't
work well with others he's got to be the
king of his own homeless castle I know
what that feels like I gotta be I gotta
I gotta have my own Kingdom with all my
homeless people's I'm surprised you
can't just invite people to sleep over
at your garage or your living room yeah
just could they smell like pee pee if
they smell fresh it was okay but they
smell like pee pee there you can't be
such a cute word they're also thinking
about like fire exits and like all those
kind of code I mean did he have like 30
people in there cuz to me that just
sounds like a Chinese family yeah you
know what I would love though I would
like for there to be public areas for
homeless people to wash and bathe
themselves but that public bathroom only
has a 15-minute time limit so they can't
do heroin inside yeah
the [ __ ] don't well they can't shower
but the one the little those green ones
in downtown do that
Oh see that's tight she's like a
10-minute limit and so in the bill I
will hide you and keep them out what
happens is if they're still but make it
is over yeah it's inside once it closes
between every use there's like a mini
like three-minute car wash where it
sprays everything inside and then it
opens up to the public that is [ __ ]
yeah we should have more of those then
yeah because that's fantastic yeah
because everything all really cuz
everybody deserves to be clean at least
if you don't want to work you at least
deserve the right to not smell maybe
there are places we just don't know and
they don't choose to clean cuz you know
I live in downtown and there's this one
guy like he only has one shoe on all the
time and then like it he has really long
old shoes I know right I know he I think
people offer him things like they okay
he just wants money
he just wants money he doesn't care
about anything else like he just you
know that's just his style people like
that though they're like oh do you want
like food all it's like I'm hungry get
yours you know buy me some Oh give me
money and then you offer them food it
like nice more money yeah you don't want
food then yeah and you are not hungry
you don't want help and and he's Asian
that's the weirdest thing yeah I've
never seen an Asian I was like I was I
was shocked like what I know he's like
an addict because like he just has track
marks and he's he's super dirty like you
can't even tell he's Asian because he
just has so much dirt on him and his
clothes are just jet-black I think he
used to be a white t-shirt that turned
black and his hair is like super long
and he goes can you spare any change sir
so he sounds like that and then he
sometimes sits down like like
cross-legged and he's like smoking a
cigarette and every time someone walks
back he goes do you have any change
it he just says that man yeah and then
like I almost looked at him and said
what happened but I didn't say it I
didn't I was like I don't want to hear
your story because it's gonna make me
sad wait question what our what our
track works track one little yeah
[Laughter]
he's a sad story man but I don't I don't
know if he only has one shoe and this is
like people's I've seen him offer like
people offer him like their food and all
that he needs like nah he doesn't want
any of that he wants cigarettes heroin
or something often I wonder what I would
do if I was homeless I used to think
about that a lot
oh [ __ ] how would I be a homeless person
like how would you spend your time how
would I spend my time how much money do
I need as a basis to live like decently
to on the streets and then what I would
buy with it and how would I get myself
back on my feet as I was so that's what
I think about so I think about this is
like at that time 24-hour memberships
was like 12 bucks a month or some [ __ ]
like that so I'll go there shower do
what I have to do go job interviews as
much as I can where would you sleep how
discretes
so I would try to Panhandle like enough
yeah money for like a motel like 40
bucks or something and then I would
think about food too I think it's easy
to get food because people always down
if you ask them specifically can you buy
me a sandwich and you stand next to like
a subway or something go buy it for you
yeah food is I think easy to get by but
I think the whole like looking
presentable and then when you want a job
you need to have paperwork like if you
don't have ID if you don't have any of
that stuff it's hard to get a job like
an alley like collect pallets if you
don't you know what that's what bums do
they collect pallets and then you can
sell each pallet for five bucks so
you'll have a huge stack of pallets on
top of a shopping cart and every single
one is five bucks I definitely would
Panhandle probably recycle should have a
little hardship for roughly about like a
year or so save up and I'm good to go
unless I'm homeless and I have a Honda
Element then my whole life is completely
different
what yours that yep because that's a
home that's a mobile home that's the
difference between men and women women
we just feel like all right I guess
we'll just like flirt with a guy then
yeah that's true yeah well girls can get
like a guy to take care of them easily
yeah well don't guys get girls to take
care of them does like a lot of guys
like you got out skills Oh
so the city here they said well we
appreciate those who have volunteered to
provide additional resources in the
community mr. Schiller's house does not
comply with codes and regulations that
guard against potential dangers such as
carbon monoxide poisoning
inadequate light and ventilation and
insufficient exits in the event of a
fire so that [ __ ] is legit though right
is dangerous
isn't the garage a big-ass exit well
that basement now it's the basement and
then they got a gas leak a [ __ ] all
those moles are dead and he's got to
clean up all those bodies the city
shouldn't be like bad bad bad they
should be like all right well let's help
you get to code and we'll work together
I think that's fog dawg
[Music]